keine aussicht auf höhere zinsen im
gegenteil die ezb verschärft ihre
politik des billigen geldes mutmaßliche
polizeigewalt in der eifel gegen einen
beamten wurden ermittelt das video wird
geprüft und aggressivität und egoismus
die mehrheit der 30 bis 59 jährigen
erlebt deutschland als
ellbogengesellschaft
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen an meiner seite
ist für den sport christian otto ich
grüße sie auch gelernt das billige geld
und eigene die sparer gefährde die
altersvorsorge und schade dem wohlstand
so lautete bisher schon die kritik an
der niedrigzinspolitik der europäischen
zentralbank jetzt hat deren präsident
draghi die zinsen noch weiter gesenkt
und angekündigt die umstrittenen
anleihekäufe wieder aufzunehmen
was das bedeutet zeigt stefan schlosser
seine amtszeit als präsident der ezb
neigt sich dem ende doch mario draghi
geht noch einmal in die vollen und dreht
den geldhahn wieder auf ab november
sollen jeden monat anleihen im wert von
20 milliarden euro gekauft werden und
banken müssen zukünftig bis zu 0,5
prozent zinsen für bei der ezb geparkt
das geld zahlen
die analyse hat gezeigt dass ein großer
grad an geldpolitischer unterstützung
weiterhin nötig ist für eine nachhaltige
annäherung der inflation an bereiche von
etwa zwei prozent
so soll die wirtschaft in schwung kommen
mehr kredite mehr investitionen
steigende preise so die hoffnung für
banken wird das geld verdienen aber noch
schwieriger sie könnten verstärkt die
kunden zur kasse bitten und eine
möglichkeit ist zu sagen dann machen wir
die einlagenzinsen negativ oder wir
schreiben die gebühren hoch das kann
durchaus passieren gleichzeitig lohnt
sich sparen kaum noch allein in diesem
jahr werden deutsche sparer und 47
milliarden euro weniger zinsen bekommen
verglichen zu einem langfristigen
durchschnitt zins und seit längerer zeit
ist die inflation auch noch höher als
die zinsen damit entstehen natürlich bei
den sparern reale verluste die sich dann
über die jahre natürlich doch deutlich
ansammeln und die private altersvorsorge
wird extrem schwierig für die deutschen
haushalte sparer bleiben die verlierer
mit den ankündigungen heute hat die
zentralbank ihr pulver langsam
verschossen wachstumsimpulse müssten
jetzt von den staaten kommen sagte mario
draghi und forderte mehr öffentliche
investitionen
damit meint er ganz sicher in erster
linie deutschland also die sparer müssen
noch mehr bluten valerie haller an der
börse in frankfurt aber bringt es dann
wenigstens der wirtschafts was also das
ist schon ziemlich umstritten
die ezb will ja mit ihrer politik
erreichen dass mehr geld in die
wirtschaft kommt für investitionen und
dadurch sollte eigentlich auch die
inflation steigen und wenn man darauf
schaut dann haben die niedrigen zinsen
nichts gebracht auch haben sie die
europäische wirtschaft nicht wirklich
angeschoben in den vergangenen jahren
die günstigen kredite die an die
unternehmen weitergereicht werden
sollten die werden kaum abgerufen und
die gelder parken die banken dann
stattdessen bei der ezb abgesehen davon
sagen kritiker dass die europäische
zentralbank mit ihren anleihen käufen
auch ein ziemlich gefährliches signal an
länder wie italien sendet sie dürfen
sich nämlich jetzt auf eine ziemlich
lange finanzierungshilfe durch die ezb
verlassen ein ansporn für reformen ist
das nicht gerade eine rezession das ist
die gute nachricht des tages in der
eurozone hält die ezb für gering sie
sagt das risiko sei ein wenig gestiegen
wenn es so weit käme dann hätte die ezb
kaum mehr pfeile im köcher dankeschön
für diese einschätzung aus frankfurt
valerie haller der bundesrechnungshof
schlägt alarm die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung der bahn sei
besorgniserregend
bis ende des jahres fehlten drei
milliarden euro heißt es in einem papier
das dem zdf vorliegt dabei müsste das
staatsunternehmen bringend investieren
eigentlich sollen viele milliarden euro
fließen unter anderem in brücken anlagen
und für mehr barrierefreiheit
zudem ist grün jetzt eine ece farbe die
bahn wirbt damit das umweltfreundlichste
verkehrsmittel zu sein und will bis 2030
doppelt so viele fahrgäste befördern
jetzt die großen finanzlücken was nun
beim 49 und cristiane hübscher an
fahrgästen fehlt es der bahn nicht aber
an geld in einem aktuellen bericht des
bundesrechnungshofes der dem zdf
exklusiv vorliegt warnen die prüfer
bereits bis ende des jahres 2009 10 wird
eine signifikante finanzierungslücke von
fast 3 milliarden euro bestehen
diese kann nicht durch eine
neuverschuldung geschlossen werden ohne
die verschuldungsgrenze zu überschreiten
neue züge die digitale china oder die
großbaustelle stuttgart 21 für solche
investitionen hat die bahn schon zum
halbjahr mehr neue schulden gemacht als
der bundestag ihr genehmigt hat die
rechnungsprüfer sehen verschärften
handlungsbedarf für den bund als
alleineigentümer der deutschen bahn ag
eigentlich hat der rechnungshof seit
jahren ja darauf hingewiesen dass die
bahn in eine zunehmende schieflage gerät
die bundesregierung hat es immer
ignoriert die fakten sind seit jahren
bekannt aber jetzt hat es also eine
dramatik erreicht in der man also
eigentlich nicht mehr weiter weg gucken
kann
die deutsche bahn ag will den bericht
nicht kommentieren spricht aber von
finanzieller stabilität klar ist helfen
kann der bahn nur geld vom bund der
verkehrsminister antwortet auf unsere
anfrage seit gestern nicht bewirbt heute
aber im bundestag seinen neuen verkehrs
et also machen wir die bahn noch besser
und wir investieren unglaublich viel in
die schiene
andreas scheuer pumpt milliarden in neue
autobahn in große privatisierungs
projekte und gleichzeitig wird bei der
schiene wird bei der bahn neben der
rotstift angesetzt das kann nicht sein
wir brauchen eine aktive waren in
deutschland für die verkehrswende für
den klimaschutz
die rechnungsprüfer empfehlen neben der
bahn tochter arriva auch den
logistikdienstleister schenker zu
verkaufen
die bahn solle sich aus dem
auslandsgeschäft zurückziehen und auf
ihren kernauftrag besinnen die heimische
eisenbahn überraschende personalie beim
verband der automobilindustrie an hat
matthes gibt seinen rücktritt als
präsident bekannt und das am
eröffnungstag der internationalen
automobilausstellung er werde sein amt
zum jahresende niederlegen und sich
neuen aufgaben widmen hieß es gründe
wurden nicht bekannt der vdh ist
gastgeber der iaa den startschuss gab
heute bundeskanzlerin merkel
sie nannte die europäischen klimaziele
für 2030 eine riesenherausforderung und
nahm die autohersteller mit in die
pflicht gemeinsam müsse man den verkehr
schnell klimafreundlicher machen
am rande der eröffnung demonstrierten
umweltaktivisten für mehr klimaschutz
die iaa ist von samstag an für alle
besucher geöffnet
der polizei im rheinland-pfälzischen
prüm ist ein verstörendes video
zugespielt worden es zeigt wie
bundespolizisten nach einer
verfolgungsjagd das fahrzeug dreier
franzosen stoppen
einer der männer wird aus dem auto
gezogen und heftig mit schlägen und
tritten malträtiert gegen einen der
beamten wird nun ermittelt wegen des
verdachts der körperverletzung im amt
angela eppert berichtet immer wieder
schlägt der polizist in der gelben jacke
auf den mann am boden ein und tritt zu
ein anonymes handy video das der polizei
übergeben wurde zeigt die festnahme
eines mannes durch beamte der
bundespolizei in prüm in der eifel
die staatsanwaltschaft trier ermittelt
nun gegen den bundespolizisten wegen des
verdachts der körperverletzung im amt in
einer mitteilung heißt es der
staatsanwaltschaft ist gestern von der
bundespolizeiinspektion trier ein video
übergeben worden dass die festnahme
eines mannes durch beamte der
bundespolizei auf dem hahnplatz in prüm
zeigt auf dem video ist zu sehen dass
einer der beamten dem festgenommenen
mehrere schläge mit einem gegenstand und
dritte versetzte der fahrer des weißen
autos soll sich zuvor einer
polizeikontrolle entzogen haben und mit
dem auto geflüchtet sein
in diesem kreisverkehr in bremen endet
die verfolgungsfahrt der polizei
die insassen drei franzosen werden
vorläufig festgenommen
auch die polizeigewerkschaft von den
aufnahmen betroffenen
und weil es so schreckliche bilder sind
müssen wir jetzt aufklären unabhängig
durch die staatsanwaltschaft und muss es
zu einem verfahren kommen um dann eben
auch b und entlastend bewerten zu können
rechtsexperten werden die schläge und
tritte als nicht tolerierbar
polizisten dürfen sich in bestimmten
situationen zur wehr setzen auch
unmittelbaren zwang ausüben das ganze
muss aber verhältnismäßig sein
geht man davon aus dass es wie du hier
echt ist hat der beschuldigte polizist
diese grenze deutlich überschritten
ihm drohen bis zu fünf jahre haft wenn
sich der verdacht bestätigen sollte
die staatsanwaltschaft betont dass die
aufnahme noch kriminaltechnisch
untersucht werden müsse
man habe aber keine hinweise dass das
video nicht echt sei was musik erreichen
kann zeigt sich gerade in der türkei
seit dem putsch versuch dort 2016 kann
ein falsches wort ein kritischer tweet
reichen und die staatsmacht schlägt zu
tausende sitzen als politische gefangene
im gefängnis
eine gruppe von rap musikern hat sich
nun getraut was viele türken nicht mehr
wagen sie klagen an
laut und deutlich und 20 millionen mal
wurde ihr video angeklickt jörg brase
aus istanbul 20 türkische rapmusiker 18
klubs ein video eine botschaft zusammen
ich kann nicht schweigen hiervor
künstler scheinlich rief seine kollegen
zusammen jeder durfte sich ein thema
wählen der in berlin geborene kurt r
gedrückt über umweltverschmutzung und
zerstörung der natur
die leute haben einfach die schnauze
voll und dieser dieser dieses lied ist
einfach ein sprachrohr geworden so hat
sich zu einem sprachrohr entwickelt was
uns wirklich alle überrascht hat sowie
hätte nie gedacht dass die leute so eine
reaktion zeigen wir sind einfach sehr
überglücklich über 20 millionen klicks
in sechs tagen ein video als
befreiungsschlag es geht um gewalt gegen
frauen jugendarbeitslosigkeit staatliche
unterdrückung junge türken sagen hier
was sie stört an ihrem land an ihrem
leben und obwohl der name des
präsidenten nie fällt ist doch klar
worum es geht
musik an jeden bewegen das video bringt
es auf den punkt was in unserem land zur
zeit abgibt
das ist sehr mutig noch wissen wir nicht
welche folgen das haben wird
aber irgendwas wird sicher passieren
einige staatsmedien reagieren wie
gewohnt das propaganda blatt yeni safak
verleugnet die künstler als terroristen
akp politiker sprechen von provokation
und manipulation bajin als kolumnistin
der zeitung hürriyet fordert von der
regierung endlich gelassener zu
reagieren
lieder zu singen solange sie nicht zur
gewalt aufrufen sollte als freie
meinungsäußerung angesehen werden selbst
wenn die lieder die regierenden
kritisieren
in der türkei ist das schon lange keine
selbstverständlichkeit mehr
wenn sie nachts kommen und dich holen
lautet ein vers in zusammenfindet du
keinen journalisten der darüber schreibt
sie sitzen alle im knast masern mann
hielt sie schon für besiegt sind wieder
dramatisch auf dem vormarsch
weltgesundheitsorganisation und eu
kommission haben auch deshalb einen impf
gipfel einberufen um im skeptikern
entgegen zu treten
denn selbst in europa grassierenden
masern und treffen oft die ärmsten in
aragon jeden tag im mai in bukarest
kinder gegen masern und doch werden hier
am nationalen institut für den schutz
von mutter und kind täglich neue
krankheitsfälle registriert allein in
dieser woche waren es 35
eine impfpflicht gibt es in rumänien
nicht es gibt zu viele arme familien die
keinen zugang zu einem arzt haben zu
viele kinder die weder rechtlich noch
medizinisch irgendwo registriert sind
weil es in ihrem dorf keinen hausarzt
gibt immer mehr masernfälle werden in
der eu registriert warnen die experten
von januar 2016 bis märz 2009 10 waren
es in rumänien 17 1850 auch in italien
und frankreich sind die zahlen
besorgniserregend
deutschland liegt mit 2093 fällen im
oberen drittel dieser statistik masern
sind hochansteckend und können tödlich
enden dennoch sind die impfquoten
rückgängig ursachen dafür sind fehlende
zugang zu medikamenten und die
wachsenden impfmüdigkeit
impfen funktioniert so das motto des
globalen impfgipfel von eu-kommission
und weltgesundheitsorganisation in
brüssel
breit angelegte kampagnen sollen viel
informationen entgegen wirken zb der
dass eine masern impfung zu autismus
führen kann
fehlinformationen werden über das
internet in lichtgeschwindigkeit
verbreitet egal ob in entwickelten oder
entwicklungsländer appellieren und
informieren kann brüssel aber keine
impfpflicht einführen denn
gesundheitspolitik ist sache der
einzelnen mitgliedsländer
eigentlich geht es der generation mitte
also den 30 bis 59 jährigen in
deutschland so gut wie lange nicht mehr
zumindest finanziell nach einer neuen
studie finden 44 prozent dass es ihnen
wirtschaftlich besser geht als noch vor
fünf jahren nur 16 prozent sagen mir
geht es schlechter was aber auffällt
eine große mehrheit klagt über
zunehmende aggressivität und egoismus
haben sie umfiel hat die details es ist
das zwischenmenschliche dass der
generation mitte sorgen bereitet zwei
drittel sehen den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt immer schwächer werden und
manchmal hat man das gefühl dass die
gesellschaft egoistischer wird eine wand
aufgebaut
für die virtuell bogen gesellschaft so
auch das ergebnis der aktuellen umfrage
in dieser altersgruppe
die große mehrheit beklagt danach
zunehmende aggressivität und wachsenden
zeitdruck viele beobachten mehr egoismus
das regeln seltener eingehalten werden
aber auch mehr fremdenfeindlichkeit vor
allem im straßenverkehr schon fast alle
befragten ein aggressiveres klima doch
über tatsächliche verhaltensänderungen
vielen wissenschaftlicher erkenntnisse
es bleiben subjektive wahrnehmung
in dieser ausprägung hat es mich
überrascht denn wenn hier fast 70
prozent die bilanz ziehen deutschland
verdient das prädikat eine
ellbogengesellschaft zu sein dann ist
das schon bemerkenswert aber warum ist
das so die konflikt forscherin sieht
auch eine neue empfindlichkeit als
ursache ja die menschen sind sensibler
geworden was eingriffe übergriffe in
ihre persönliche integrität betrifft und
die gesellschaft ist diverser geworden
also viel viel mehr menschen haben das
gefühl sie müssen solche übergriffe
nicht mehr hinnehmen auch dass ein
umfrageergebnis nicht schule politik
oder medien könnten dem egoismus am
ehesten entgegen wirken 85 prozent sehen
hier elternhaus und familie gefordert
der südosten spaniens erlebt zurzeit die
heftigsten regenfälle seit 100 jahren
in drei provinzen gilt die höchste
warnstufe incau dete ertrank ein ehepaar
in den wassermassen
in einem ort südlich von valencia wurden
fast 200 menschen gerettet oder
vorsorglich in sicherheit gebracht
dort fielen seit gestern fast 300 liter
regen auf den quadratmeter und es regnet
weiter sehr stark
wir sind beim sport unter steht ein
spannender bundesliga tag an
nach der länderspielpause der bvb fühlt
sich eigentlich stark genug für den
titel
doch nach dem 1 3 bei aufsteiger union
berlin steht vize meister borussia
dortmund bereits am vierten spieltag
unter erfolgsdruck
die partie gegen leverkusen gleichzeitig
das erste duell zweier langjähriger
teamgefährten gemeinsam stark noch in
der vergangenen saison bei havas und
julian brandt das 20 jährige supertalent
herz zog es vor noch eine saison in
leverkusen zu reifen sein freund folgte
den sportlich größeren erfolgsaussichten
nach dortmund ich glaube eine gute
chance einfach wieder zu zeigen dass das
gerade nachdem nach der niederlage in
berlin dass wir
dass wir wieder zurückkommen die
niederlage in berlin ein schock beim
selbsternannten meisterkandidaten wurden
sogleich ursachen gesucht der oft
zaudernden trainer lucien favre
das thema ist nicht neu und nervt nur
wir kriegen kein punkt mehr wenn wir
jedes mal wieder neu erzählen sondern
wir sollten vielmehr das augenmerk
darauf legen was auf dem spielfeld
geschieht die länderspiel pause kam
gerade recht spielemacher witzel ist
wieder dabei
der wunsch der anhänger in die knie
gehen sollen die spieler möglichst nur
im training nach silber soeben nun auch
noch gold für die deutschen bei den
schwimm weltmeisterschaften der
behinderten in london über 100 meter
brust gewann die stark sehbehinderte
weltrekordhalterin elena kraftstoff aus
berlin in einer minute 13,62 sekunden
[Applaus]
trotz der dritten niederlage
nacheinander hat deutschlands baseball
nationalmannschaft bei der
europameisterschaft in bonn das
viertelfinale erreicht doch gegen
italien sollte es morgen besser laufen
als beim 6 zu 10 gegen tschechien das
deutsche team in weiss geht mit 2 0 in
führung doch dann geht alles ganz
schnell und die tschechen ziehen 9 zu 2
davon
pascal amon früher mal profi in den usa
kann nach einem schlag alle vier ecken
des spielfelds ablaufen und einen punkt
erzielen
vielmehr gelingt den deutschen nicht
sechs zu ziehen geht das spiel verloren
als gruppenvierter ist deutschland
denner unter den besten acht im
viertelfinale
die besten fünf bei der em bestreiten
schon nächste woche ein
qualifikationsturnier für olympia
also alles noch möglich richtung tokio
und wir gehen noch ein bisschen weiter
als tokio nämlich richtung alle gibt es
da oben noch anderes leben diese frage
beschäftigt die menschheit seit
jahrhunderten hier auf dem sogenannten
exoplaneten k2 18b könnte es möglich
sein das glauben astronomen vom
university college london
denn sie haben dort mit hilfe des
weltraumteleskops hubble temperaturen
wie bei uns und wasser nachgewiesen
der grundstoff für das leben wie wir es
kennen eine reise dorthin ist allerdings
kein katzensprung der planet im
sternbild löwe ist 110 lichtjahre
entfernt
unsere sonne ist da zum glück sehr viel
näher und gibt in den nächsten tagen
noch mal alles morgens sind noch ein
paar wolken davor sagt gleich katja
hornuf aber am wochenende winken
temperaturen bis zu 30 grad christian
sievers begrüßten heute einmal um
viertel vor zehn
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen herrlichen
abend uns enorm wieder da wenn sie mit
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren heute
gab es viele wolken graue wolken und die
brachten zum teil auch so im richtigen
tropfen wirbel mit das sehen sie hier
ganz gut an diesen weißen flächen und
manchmal führte sich tatsächlich auch
eine elster für unsere kameralinse
richtig dichte wolken gab es in teilen
der mitte und die temperaturen heute
lagen zwischen 20 und 25 grad am
wärmsten wurde es bei strahlendem
sonnenschein am oberrhein
und da ist es dann in der nacht unter
klarem himmel auch am kältesten von
nordwesten kommt schon wieder der
nächste regen heran und die temperaturen
in norddeutschland sind nur auf 16 bis
14 grad da wird es dann über tag gar
nicht so viel wärmer
da sind das 18 19 grad richtung
mittelgebirge geht es auf 20 bis 22 grad
schon am mittag erreichen die
regenwolken der nach dem südraum der
nördlichen mittelgebirge und dann reißen
die wolken hier nordöstlich der elbe wie
auch an der nordsee ganz schön auf bei
einem böigen wind aus nordwestlichen
richtungen
auch in süddeutschland ist es morgen zum
teil trübe aber südlich von karlsruhe
stuttgart und nürnberg kommt die sonne
immer besser zum zuge und dort steigen
dann auch die temperaturen auf 24 bis 26
grad noch etwas wärmer wird es dann am
samstag und am sonntag vielleicht sogar
bis 30 grad